hello welcome to this 2510 game against
GM BMW who said the Grand Master with
the BMW okay he's not actually a GM
title holder so the way okay i was
thinkin about maybe goin g 6 but ok well
the exchange line is not a big issue so
it just tends to lead to boring games
just it just is a line that sometimes
doesn't yeah it's not very exciting ok
he's playing quickly um Queen g6 I think
what would be five I think to d5 is
actually right just all the way back
home let's say ok so
he has no particular ambition here it
seems just once the development be okay
when the demon is giving he has given me
the bishop pair from no particular
compensation there should be six it's 95
so I'm going to prepare that okay the
compensation that you could argue about
it that he's better developed even
though the position doesn't look exactly
like someone losing quickly due to lack
of development my ideas we should be six
and then cancelled short okay so he
wants to play knight c6 if I castle okay
there should be six and now I'm also
attacking the default porn and I think I
will take it if he is insisting to offer
me however mean that home I mean let's
say Bishop f4 i think i will take the
pawn
it's interesting that if I castle he
might be able to check on f7 anyway as a
bishop of 17 FC seven is a pawn and
night f7 Rugare 726 also is a porn so
okay that move of course I didn't look
at interesting I really should have
considered the move I was sloppy play on
my part I don't think it's it's a big
issue but I should have I mean should
have been aware of the possibility and
that f4 maybe
hmm maybe night at four
yeah yeah I can cancel longneck smooth
or is he trying something drastic like
f4 know
okay queen bee for attacking d 4 + b2
yep no wait it's got 35 let's think a
little bit
yeah it is why what is really difficult
is to imagine how to win such a position
here
Jim
not many active ideas possible for
either side I could have played 95
already trade nights that see you more
boring so Bishop g4 yeah doesn't it
isn't too much but I can threaten it why
not maybe I get in Bishop d5 and can
maybe I can provoke him to treat the
night against the bishop I don't want to
have a night in this position with the
symmetrical pawns where is not problem
at all
yeah okay here i can go nite h5 not
quite sure about the move but I think I
think I'm do that it just looks like
something that injects some life into
the position and some some continuations
are just good yeah i mean like Queen age
for Bishop g4 I think you will go to e3
I guess even though it looks kind of
weird no F Bishop g4 then hmm did you
screw up here a little bit
yep it should be for now that's a double
attack hook 1 t1 bishop on f4 it's
funnier just like three moves ago I was
saying it's hard to imagine someone
using this position and white managed to
do that in three moves um is he losing I
think he is that that's the only
possible continuation I think it might
not do some direct material so i think i
will take only one that should be the
right continuation yeah check I will
rupee one
no it's okay it's okay ruki one I can
take bishop f3
it is not winning not directly winning
this position at least I don't see it
rookie one Bishop f3 this may be rook to
e7 I can take you for anyway no
okay I don't understand what he's doing
here Queen takes Knight Air Force just
just drew just very bad so he has to
take where the rook I think hmm strange
so let's look I was thinking Bishop of
three years right note F for Queen takes
d4 doesn't look so convincing if i take
g4 here this Bishop e3 and this is kind
of offer so i think i will take now g
takes a 3 24 he doesn't have Bishop e3
it's nice
so any move that he can play I'm also
threatening g5 now as he has got nothing
to check on g4 so looks pretty bad I was
playing the game very quickly that's
quite lucky that 96 shot I forgot about
and everybody forgot about it because I
think this happened to me before it came
no idea but what you should play I mean
if he moves the bishop okay i'm thinking
you move the bishop arana channel i
think that was a better way of being a
pawn down was he I Scott rookie for wow
did I screw up here I simply didn't
think of this at all
so 90 x f4 rupee form
hmm
whoa
it's pre awful oh my god if I check on
c4 is got 92 unfortunately
I don't have a check after night afore
looking for amazing no check no
intermediate moves
Wow
wow he really stumbled into this
nonsense amazing yeah okay I bet he
finds of course solji 554 takes on h4
get for another piece down
down to side with the piece down amazing
you played this weird stuff and somehow
maybe I made a mistake somewhere I took
that that that's we're just just very
weird to allow all that and then by
miracle if yes this Ruby for business so
you took with the Queen here okay
probably many things win rookie to look
simple actually ok I have three points I
just recognize that three three pawns
group in verse I don't know i saw in
salsa I mean this is expressionist kind
of inappropriate probably i'm not sure
if it could have been worse but i mean
at least um them there might be some
ways for him to screw it up I don't have
much material that's a little bit bad
his King is a potential problem but
I think Queen g4 is not a bad choice
here just going to the endgame straight
away but it's not necessary you can also
play other things like strengthening
moves like King f2 or so I don't have
any any great idea Ruby 7 is also
check yeah yeah that will serve the
simple cleanse not bad I think so let's
take and see you here
I'm not sure ready how to defend here
rookie for maybe activating I mean my
goal is to trade down the pawns and then
draw against Luke annoyed I mean of
course you can argue like three points
isn't that kind of equal to the to the
piece yeah on paper but the thing is
that pieces can take the pawns but the
pawns rarely take the piece and turn in
many cases the piece will be will be
stronger let's see he i can at least my
king is in the middle kind of
participating night there i am ok group
d to with something well hmm not sure
about it here anyway I think be six
should be prevented if he goes Rudi to
now at least um that end game is reached
in a situation where my king is pretty
active I can go see five it's
interesting
who did you I can go see five that's
very important I guess yeah I have Sofia
it's much better version of the Rope
trade if he takes now that would that
would that wouldn't be clearer than I
really if he takes on d4 and I get the
get my opponents straightened out
it might still be better for white so
King 23 King defies then 90 to be three
and my pawns are blocked for the moment
but this is this is getting interesting
I don't think I would have straightened
out the black pawn chain him i don't i
don't think it was necessary for him to
do that good move I guess
Kingda five King be five text x 92 Jerry
but I don't have many options here the
only thing I could go f5 Teague skin
tags maybe maybe at least the peso that
would would that I would get would be
pretty pretty outside ticks ticks 93
King e5 King be three though yeah I
think I go King be fine
so g six then f five
I don't think it said so bad if I go at
five now f5 I mean he certainly can draw
at any anytime but can you win I'm not
sure about it not be six kings is six
maybe he can somehow come around with
the night but he has to be quite
cautious there check so King here King
c8 King c8 king d 7 that seems to be a
draw check that's a draw
night see aid I cannot go for Winnie I
think it would be quite insane at four
don't think so
no it's each f4
and it's a lot a good idea what but can
have him he might be able to put me into
a Zook swung by the way this is very
much possible yeah that's possible maybe
you can zhuzh check out wrong yeah I
have to take that role I think I was
just thinking maybe he can zoosk upon me
by going back let's say like age 5 h 4
okay i can go here
yeah the engine is very cool blooded and
says it's a draw check check okay very
weird game so probably let's let's have
a look there i mean i want to check a
couple of things so this looks fairly
normal like here this and now yet this
night is six business yeah hmm and stock
wish wants to do this oops sorry queen's
eggs and it doesn't like em this this
funny idea work is separate aqueous have
no key 8 and the morning okay so this is
the thing that should take on g6 but ok
i don't think this is a big big problem
ok be three years given by the computer
not taking only seven a nice idea okay
but what happened in the game i remember
Lee took curious about things this just
looks awful check again the engine just
is very equipped quite a bit this and
Queen takes and i'm just a pawn up for
nothing this is what i should do yeah of
course I mean I had seen this Jay I
didn't see the rookie form beforehand
okay here Ruby seven was very strong I
go here he will take take yeah so check
it check and then King here until white
wins the way it went wasn't wasn't that
clear check yeah the engine also wants
to keep the Queen's Own might be bad i
am i was i was thinking some move like
this and just continue with the Queen's
but check this is maybe not losing maybe
not but it looks bad I was briefly
thinking about this but check it looks a
bit weird looks very slow
I like I like that the continuation a
bit better that's probably really a draw
I mean it didn't let's see here and then
am i running out of moves here probably
not i mean i can shuffle with the king
and whenever he tries to activate his
night i will get in c4 wine those pawns
will be quite dangerous you have a tough
game and i missed my chance to say i
didn't see that rookie formal not very
difficult to see but I still missed it
okay well thanks for watching